[Music]
a of light through
the welcome to zana's insightful
conversations where we develop into
important topics that impact impact the
lives of teenagers I'm your host zaa and
today we're addressing a press pressing
issue the mental health of teenagers and
the unique struggles they've been facing
during these challenging
times
[Music]
sh teenagers are often described as a
role roller coaster of emotions but the
past few years have taken that roller
coaster to a whole new level the co 19
pandemic social
isolation and the UN the uncertainty of
the future have created The Perfect
Storm for teenager mental health
[Music]
challenges according to the CDC the
percentage of high school students
experienced ing persistent feelings of
sadness or hopelessness increased
significantly during the pandemic this
is a clear indicator that teenagers have
been carrying a heavy
[Music]
burden one of the most common struggles
teenagers have faced is the disruption
of their normal routines schools move to
Virtual learning extracurricular
activities were cancelled and the
friendships were limited to online
interactions these abrupt CH these
abrupt changes left many feeling
disconnected and
isolated even though during this time we
connected so much throughout Tik Tok and
Instagram and Snapchat there was still
that empty feeling that everything was
just through social media and we will
never have human interactions ever again
we wouldn't know we wouldn't know if
we're going to be free tomorrow if we're
going to be out of isolation or if we're
going to be stuck for
years for teenagers the social aspect of
school is essential it's where they
build friendships it's where they build
their identity and where they learn to
navigate the complex terrain of
relationships with the closer with the
closure of
school
um and lockdowns many teens lost that
vital support
system Additionally the pressure to
excel academically has continued or even
increased during this time teens are
juggling the demands of remote learning
while dealing with the emotional toll of
the pandemic creating a perfect recipe
for Stress and Anxiety it's crucial that
we re-evaluate academic expectations
and focus on overwhel wellbeing we don't
have to be perfect and have straight A's
or be perfect in our looks or be good at
dancing we don't we can't be good at
everything we're only humans
but the standards are so high that we
can't even reach them but we force
ourselves to try and do that but we
can't do that obviously so this causes
Stress and Anxiety for our future and
for our throughout
days uh um social media is another
Factor contributing to the mental health
challenges of teenagers the constant
comparison to others on platforms like
Instagram and Tik Tok can lead to
negative self-perception and feelings of
inadequacy or we also experience the
fear of missing out which is also called
fomo is more
[Music]
even though these social media platforms
have caused a negative impact on us it's
also taught us about other things we've
been connecting with other people
throughout the world I myself made many
online friends throughout the the
country the the continents or and in
other continents we really reached out
to other people and we got to know other
people and we shared and talked about
our problems where we don't really feel
that alone when we're socializing but
you go on Tik Tok or you go on Instagram
and you see somebody and you think oh my
God they're doing so good they're so
famous or they're so good at school they
got accepted to Harvard
whatever everything on social media is
fake and I think that we really need to
learn that and we need to lower the
standards on our physical appearance or
academic
success
never knew I could
feel that's the way
[Music]
I he can't see the smile I'm
F the pandemic has also highlighted the
importance of access to Mental Health
Resources for teenagers
um have been open to the
world many have struggled to find the
support when they needed it the
most um social media also had multiple
multiple people going out on platforms
and speaking about the mental our mental
health and trying to help us in a way
but the stigma surrounding mental health
issues prevent some from seeking help
and we need to break down these barriers
especially especially the generations
before us like our parents generations
and the generation before that doesn't
really believe in the mental health
mental health issues teenagers can have
they believe that only adults can be
stressed only adults can be depressed
when they don't know that the pandemic
and social media have been such a hard
toll on our mental health cuz they
didn't have social
media telling them that they should look
a certain way but they did they had
magazines they had movies whatever
podcasts radio shows that told them oh
you should look like this you should
look like that um
social social preferences have always
been an impact in people's lives and
mental healths but they never really
took it as seriously as they do
[Music]
now
it's essential for parents Educators and
the society as a whole to recognize
these struggles and provide the
necessary
support creating open conversations
about mental health reducing academic
pressure and fostering resilience can
make a significant difference in the
lives of
teenagers schools could have a certain
hour where students could pick when they
feel stressed or anxious to have it to
themselves then make up for that hour
obviously throughout the week but they
should just have a time to take take a
breather sit down smell the roses and
calm down because a math test is not
going to Define our whole entire future
uh a a report on a book is not going to
Define our future it's not going to kill
us it's not going to hurt us it's not
going to do anything but the way the
system has been made is constantly
constantly constantly putting pressure
on us and making us think that our
grades Define who we are but that's not
true cuz you could be the smartest
person ever you could have the worst
grades so I feel like that should the
main main main step of helping teenager
mental health is academic pressure to
reduce
that
by day
[Music]
up in conclusion it's crucial that we
acknowledge the challenges that
teenagers are facing in their mental
health the past few years have been
unpredictable and it's okay for
teenagers to seek help and take care of
their well-being let's work together to
ensure they have the res resources and
the support they need to
[Music]
[Applause]
thrive M Night who you you know to C I
[Music]
know if you or
someone
[Music]